انتهاك استيطاني جديد بحق الفلسطينيين هذه
المره في قمه جبل القبيبات فوق اراضي
قريتي برقه وسيله الظهر بين جنين ونابلس
فبعد شهرين على الغاء حكومه الاحتلال
قانون فك الارتباط في شمال الضفه الغربيه
اقتحمت مجموعات استيطانيه متطرفه ليلا
بؤره حومش الاستيطانيه المخلاه منذ عام
2005 واعادت ارساء بيوت متنقله تمثل مدرسه
دينيه في موقع جديد داخل البؤره بدعم من
وزراء حكومه اليمين المتطرف وحمايه جيش
الاحتلال في محاوله لشرعنه البؤره
هذه لحظه تاريخيه نحن على بعد خطوات
معدوده لتصحيح الظلم الرهيب بترحيل سكان
حومش منذ ذلك الوقت ونحن نعمل ليل نهار
لتصحيح الظلم الشخصي ليس فقط بحق
المطرودين وانما بحق امتي ودوله اسرائيل
بعد تسع سنوات على اخلائهم تحجج متطرفون
بالعوده اليها لاداء طقوس دينيه وهو ما
رافقه تعزيز للوجود العسكري في المنطقه
واستمرار اعتداءات المستوطنين وتعطيل حياه
الاف الفلسطينيين
كل مره بتصير شادي ابو عمر قال انهم
تمكنوا خلال السنوات الاخيره من انتزاع
اربعه قرارات من المحاكم الاسرائيليه لمنع
عوده المستوطنين الى حومش
الحكومه ضربه بعرض الحائط كل القرارات
واللي اخذناها من المحكمه الاسرائيليه
واجت وضعت حجر الاساس لمستوطنه حومش ولكن
هذا يشكل هاجس للشعب الفلسطيني والاهلي
بركه ولا الكره المجاوره سباسطي بالزاريا
والمناطق المجاوره ولكن في ارادتنا وقوتنا
لن تعود حامش
وفي ظل الاجراءات الاستيطانيه الاسرائيليه
احاديه الجانب المرفوضه من قبل المجتمع
الدولي ادانت مؤسسات حقوقيه اسرائيليه
واوساط رسميه فلسطينيه هذه الخطوه هذه
شرعنا لبؤره عشوائيه
تندرج في اطار محاولات دوله الاحتلال
تحويل طابع الصراع من سياسي الى ديني
اسرائيل تستغل ازدواجيه المعايير الدوليه
وتسابق الزمن من اجل تسريع عمليات الضم
التدريجي الزاحف للضفه الغربيه المحتله
اعاده المستوطنين المتطرفين تشييد مدرسه
دينيه في بؤره حومش الاستيطانيه تترجم
مساعي الحكومه اليمنيه للحفاظ على
توليفتها من اجل مصالح المستوطنين لكن هذا
الواقع ينذر بتعزيز فرص العوده الى مشاهد
التوتر والغليان مع تصدي الفلسطينيين في
القرى المجاوره لهذه المشاريع الاستيطانيه
سمير ابو شمالي الجزيره نابلس فلسطين